all right Sam yeah Sam uh where did you
grow up where are you from originally
green ver North
Carolina tell tell me about your uh
family growing up you had both your
parents yeah well I got four brothers
and uh I got uh my parents my my
father he molested all the boys and and
my mother was on
drugs and we count like grew up in the
street a lot of times not nothing to
eat and
um my brother older brother now I'm the
youngest they um picked on me
and and
uh I just mostly stayed to myself
depressed and because my brothers picked
on me and my
father he molested us and
uh my mother wasn't there to help us and
uh
so I just um stayed to myself I was
scared of
people growing up and I'm still a little
scared of people growing up you know how
long did this go on huh how long did
this go on my whole life till I ran away
from home but you started it started
what age for you when I ran away from
home I was maybe about 28 no but you
when the your father started molesting
you how old were you oh I
was we was like six or
seven I I don't like to talk about it
because it's it's still I have
nightmares about
it what did you and your brothers do at
the time did you tell anybody or no cuz
we were scared and my father say he was
going to kill us if we tell
anybody so we kind of like well I I I
kept
quiet and when I got 28 I ran away from
home and I traveled all over the world I
lived in Arizona and Las
Vegas I live uh in Atlanta I just
traveled and stayed in
shelters
have you ever had a job or never had a
job no nothing I
uh I I had a dream I jumped out of
planes and helicopters in the Army but I
wasn't never in the
Army do do you feel like what your
father did to
you kind of changed the way you are able
to deal with the world yeah yeah
definitely
because I I I don't trust nobody I
um I don't hang with nobody I stay to
myself I'm I'm more like scared of
people so I don't
uh I don't communicate with people I
just got an apartment A Week
Ago part of the housing that they're
giving out to people yeah cuz uh I was
on the street for 30 years you're in
skro
yeah yeah are drugs a part of your life
no I I don't even drink I don't do
drugs yeah I I smoke some
marijuana yeah but you don't uh you
don't get get involved in all the stuff
that everyone else down here no no no no
you're you're one of the very very few
yeah I I stay to myself sir I don't
uh I'm scared of people I can't trust
nobody you feel like what your dad did
to you just yeah made you unable to yeah
I never had a
girlfriend you know I don't even know
what a woman feel
like but it don't bother me because of
you know it don't bother me because you
know um what my father
did yeah did you and your brothers talk
about it to each other no when we were
little and now I I I ain't seen my
family my brothers I I don't know where
they
at you know they we all went our
separate ways I I ain't been in contact
with them I don't know where they at you
have older brothers or younger or both
I'm the youngest they they the oldest so
the older ones didn't say hey this is
crazy or anything like that I don't know
I don't know where they at no but when
when it was going on oh yeah no
they they didn't do
nothing nobody did nothing we was we was
afraid our d
just accept he was a big guy you just
accept it and it becomes what's normal
in the family yeah and so I just um I
ran
away I still have
nightmares yeah I I stay in I just got
an apartment a week ago and I just stay
in the house
and and and I don't say nothing to
nobody it was hard for me to even talk
to that guy he was talking to me telling
me tell my
story what kind of I don't want to be
too personal but what kind of stuff
would your dad do do to you well he
uh he um sucked
them on our privacy and and he just used
to rub on us you
know and your mom was unable to do
anything about it she was on
drugs
yeah she was on
drugs you know that went on
for almost all my life I
mean up until I was like maybe
really
that's a long time
yeah I see a psychiatrist
now and I talk to him that's great yeah
it helps a little
bit what do you wish you had done
differently in your life if anything I
don't know because I don't know
uh was like in the dark all all the time
my whole life you know I don't know
nothing different but I don't
um I'm not gay or nothing I just um I
just don't be to myself I I don't I
don't be around people man I don't I
don't be a part of that no more in my
life I don't be a part of that no more
Papa it's great that you stayed away
from the drugs and alcohol
yeah little marijuana and that's
it rest of the stuff I don't
want what what emotions do you go
through oh my God are you angry or
depressed or yeah confused it's a lot of
stuff I see a
psychiatrist and I have to vent way I
feel all the time twice a month I go see
him I've been with him 12 years now lot
of anger
huh a lot of anger
yeah I I've been with him 12 years
Papa anything else you want to know is
is
hurtful that's a terrible thing for a
young man to go through no it changes I
don't know I don't know I don't know
happiness what is
that I come out I get me a little food
and cuz I don't have
anything and I'm uh satisfied with what
I
get did you feel loved as a as a child
no what did
that I don't hurt nobody I I wouldn't
hurt
nobody just stay away from people
man it's all I
do
what's your greatest fear now huh what's
your greatest fear
now somebody hurting me or or I'm
hurting somebody I don't want to do none
of that so you know to protect myself I
stay to
myself 62
now I still have nightmares your
father's gone
I guess so I I ran away I you you don't
even know yeah I don't
know ran away
Papa I just take life
um one minute at a
time
no I don't know did you ever have dreams
of doing something with your life I
don't know nothing about it I don't know
I wasn't
Tau I wasn't
taught so I think I'm too old
now so I just uh a lot of people social
workers help me you
know psychiatrist they help me
yeah I just learned
how the last uh year I just learned how
to
pray
you
know to think of that is is is it's
really bad is it make me feel real real
bad it's it was a nightmare Papa it
wasn't no stableness
nothing just thank God I never been in
the jail or nothing like
that never had handcuffs on me
yet cuz I don't do nothing I stay to
myself I don't hang out with crowds of
people always think people out to plot
against
you but that's what my daddy
did Papa how
long how long I have to tell
you talk about this no we're good we're
good let me ask you one more
question Sam what what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your
life how to
pray that's a goodest thing I've ever
learned in this lifetime 62 years old
how to pray it helps you that's it help
me and my
mind cuz see I always hear voices
now I thank you
pop y always he voice
and I just don't act on the voices what
did the voices tell
you to lash out to hurt somebody
to take revenge for what happened to me
man are you angry at your father yeah
what would you do if if you could see
your dad now what would you
do I couldn't even think about what I do
I want to do
probably kill
him and kill
myself I don't I don't think about it
because I ain't seen
them and I'm long ways from where I'm
from okay Papa all right Sam thank you
so much for sharing your
story